so today i'm at the university of sydney
with uh steve bosey
and we are exploring everyone's favorite
state of matter uh plasma well actually
my favorite state of matter is the bose
einstein condensate but that's just
that's for another episode so for now we
are trying to replicate uh these videos
that you can see on the web where people
use a simple grape and a microwave to
produce plasma
we took a grape and cut it part of the
way through so you'd have two halves
with a tiny little isthmus of grape skin
holding the two halves together
put that in the microwave oven now try
to prop that up
so it's sitting in the middle
and all set is this going to be
dangerous
uh i don't think so but uh we are
experts so
be careful if you're trying this at home
and bingo
where's the plasma whoa
there's the plasma
oh
wow well that was some pretty amazing
plasma that we made in this microwave
um what is plasma for people who don't
know okay if you take a gas and you put
lots of energy into it until it gets
very hot and the particles are very very
energetic
you start to rip electrons off the
molecules so you end up with a soup
made up of negatively charged electrons
mixed in
but moving freely with a bunch of
positively charged
air molecules and why does that give off
light
well any time that you put energy into
atoms and molecules the electrons start
moving around changing orbits and that
kind of stuff so
anytime the electrons are being excited
and
and de-excited you're going to get light
whoa
who needs drugs and we also imagine that
it's very hot so it would be glowing
white hot anyway yeah possibly also some
of the ingredients in in that plasma
uh i've actually been heated up very
high so they're incandescent they just
glow because they're hot
i don't know so so what did we find work
the best with uh microwaving our grape
what lessons did we learn
okay first thing we discovered was we
got better results if we dried the grape
up before we put it in we found too much
water together too much steam they tend
to extinguish the
plasma and then steve came up with a
great idea of actually
cutting the grape completely in half but
using these dangling flaps of
grape skin and grafting them together
just laying them over the top of each
other and that seemed to work better
because we could reduce the volume of
the grape and that seemed to to help
yeah but because we used smaller pieces
of grape
so we had less steam also less thermal
mass
and possibly more less grape absorbing
less microwave energy so we've got
higher
fields holy
species oh yes did you see that fireball
that was an example of multiple plasma
and then of course the trick was to try
to capture the plasma so that we didn't
do damage to the microwave for one thing
and second of all so that we could
observe it quite nicely in in a
container
but we had trouble with the glass that
we were using a few glasses yes you
could get it to work the guess
is that the glass was absorbing too much
of the microwave energy and so
we weren't getting very high fields you
need to make the plasma oh
yeah oh
no so we moved over to a plastic
container which seemed to do
much better yeah if you can just
tolerate the fact that the plastic
container melted afterwards
plastic container to capture the action
and adventures
go the laws of physics yeah oh yeah
it's still going
do you smell that is that a new smell is
that a melting plastic are you still
filming
oh my god catch that look it's got a
smile even this
even the containers got a smiley face
after that run
yeah it's uh it's only like a one-hit
gig
so uh what sort of future investigations
would you like to do here okay now
in order to understand exactly why this
happens
um we really need to be able to control
the variables inside that grape okay we
we can't control the ingredients of a
grape they come to us as is
so what we'd like to do is make a an
artificial grape so we i don't know get
cotton balls we can put uh conductive
liquid in it you know we can put salty
water in it we can put grape juice
and control the volume of these things
so one by one we can actually um
nail down the different uh variables and
we'll have to find some
some artificial skin to replace the
grape skin i don't know if it has to be
grape skin maybe
maybe a wet piece of paper might do the
job i don't know
okay so you should look forward to that
on another episode of veritasium
care for a grape thank you very much
hmm physics is tasty
oh lee
oh see what did i tell you what did i
tell you
have to like the small no i think that's
it